un bashung c'était votre mari avec lui
vous avez une petite pop et qui a
maintenant aujourd'hui sept ans c'est ça
alors à 8 ans 8 ans elle habite en donc
vous êtes chanteuse que l'on sait c'est
important de le dire et vous tenez et
particulièrement à ces à cet album qui
est sorti cette année par la rivière
c'est joséphine musique 14 titres alors
on va dire ambiance funk entrée assez
langoureux
je trouve alors je vais maintenant vous
laisser face au miroir pour nous lui
dire votre passion pour alain bashung
qui a commencé un certain jour et vous
allez nous dire peut-être le moment et
après on parlera il reviendra sur
comment ces rencontres pourraient oui
comment vous être encourues c'est vrai
on s'est rencontré sur le plateau de
tournage du clip la nuit je mens de
jacques audiard jacques audiard n'est
pas jacques audiard
voilà je suis arrivé sur le plateau je
l' ai vu au loin il chantait tout de
suite je me suis dit ah oui c'est un
homme pour moi oui oui tout de suite
vous êtes comme ça ouais et et puis tout
de suite a été électrique c'était très
c'était s'était présenté dans l'air quoi
cci bennati ans vous avez quel âge à
l'époque j'avais 24 ans lui et il en
avait 25 de plus un de son enfant c'est
ce qui nous a parlé tout sur blessure au
bassin enfance c'était plutôt triste
mais je sais plus tôt des souvenirs
tristes sinon enfance brisée 1
c'est un père inconnu donc un père
adoptif
mais pas assez d'argent à boulogne pour
pour l'élever donc la maman et le beau
père qui envoie l'un
chez les grands parents alsaciens
adoptive et puis là là c'est une enfance
dur quoi ou ou voilà par des grands
parents agriculteurs ce qui pourrait
être chouette mais c'était pas ça
l'était pas du tout donc voilà on
l'appelait le bâtard c'est comme ça
quand même
alors il me disait qu'il faisait du vélo
il aimait faire du vélo ça le salon lui
vider la tête de faire du vélo
je crois que ça ça le way s'échapper
comme ça ça et les radios allemandes
c'est comme ça qu'il a écoutées du
rock'n'roll
jerry lee lewis tout ce qu'il a voilà
qui l'a réveillé quoi ah oui ses débuts
mais vous en raconter ses débuts alors
oui j'ai c'est qu'il y faisait un petit
groupe avec les gens de l'école et je
sais que le curé leur laisser un local
de répétition ça il m'en a parlé et
après quand il est venu à paris ça a été
plus difficile bon il s'est vraiment
brouillé avec ses parents et puis ça a
été un peu la galère comme jusqu'à trois
ans jusqu'à jusqu'à gaby c'était
difficile mais après dans sa dans sa
carrière premier enregistrement
qu'est ce qu'ils en encaissent qui me
retenait luxe et ses premières aventures
45 tours
oui oh il fut lee était pas très fier de
ses premières aventures musicales il l'a
ramenée pas trop avec ça il me disait
que c'était voilà c'est ça devait avoir
lieu et puis c'est passage obligé mais
voilà c'était pas à retenir quoi il a
fait des rencontres avec dany brillant
avec a décrit videur d'écrivain c'est
pareil avec des vraiment ouais il a
managé disparaît
c'était sa grande star moi bien sûr où
il a des bons souvenirs il avait des
bons souvenirs de dick
oui je pense que c'est passé à travers
tout ça qu'il a approché le showbiz
petit à petit et puis et voilà et la
finition
je n'ai pas réussi à vraiment alors la
réussite justement c'est gaby gaye wes
énorme 1980 et enfin ces trois ans à oui
oui puis c'était une face b
oui sauf que c'était pas des bases
acquises et le public quoi visiter tout
surpris que ce soit la face b qui marche
et après je crois que c'est ressorti en
face à
oui c'est ça on veut bien sûr comme ça
se fait mais on a l'impression qu'il a
toujours remis en question ses succès
c'est à dire que s'est jamais installé
par gaby oh gaby ça aurait pu tourner la
tête un jeune commune ouais mais c'est
un chercheur toujours en expérience
cherchons les expériences les émotions
non une fois qu'ils avaient fait le tour
de quelques chose
c'est autre chose parce qu'après kabylie
abus on l'attend au tournant il sans
vertige de l'homme est passé à appeler
blessure je sais que ça bon on
l'attendait pas là quoi on attend du
malawi savez 15 bourg la voilà il y
tenait beaucoup
oui il y avait un grand oui bah oui
c'était un peu le maître et l'élève quoi
alors il m'avait parlé un peu de cette
relation qui sentait tous les deux qu'il
fallait pas que le maître mange l'élève
ni que l'élève mange le maître et puis
c'était une espèce de respect un peu
tendu comme ça entre les deux et oui
travailler l'après midi puis l'histoire
et faisait la tournée des grands ducs
mais c'était une belle relation il avant
abandon il ya une vie avant vous une
ville à part turquie et sur comment il
était parce que c'est pas su comment il
était comme un père parce qu'il a
peut-être issus mais je n'ai pas vu en
paire avec arthur donc je peux pas vous
parler de ça je les ai vus en paire avec
copé de ce qui était un père absolument
fou de sa fille très attentif
passant des heures à dessiner très
proches mais lui il dit lui-même que
pour son premier freestyle n'a pas eu
cette disponibilité là une équipe en
dentelle je pense pas parce qu'il était
dans une espèce d'élan comme ça dans
volent de succès bon les circonstances
étaient certainement pas les mêmes il ya
un aspect de bashung qu'on oublie c'est
l'acteur l'extra il a tourné dans treize
films quand même pour le dernier jeu
soit rêvé d'être un gangster de
benchetrit lui fait un duo avec armand
car seulement extraordinaire rien ça
s'est il vous parle est un petit peu de
ce qu'il aimait ça e comme me disais
c'était un peu des vacances pour dire
que c'était reposant ils étaient pris en
charge
il avait pas faire quoi
donc ça ça me reposais il voit là il
était au service de quelqu'un est l
outil de quelqu'un
e
et tant mieux si c'était une belle
histoire à raconter mais ils ne voyaient
pas plus que ça il sentait pas qu'il
avait un talent terrible enfin qu'il
avait lavé pas du tout non il est
quelqu'un de très modeste donc pas du
tout un non non il savait jamais comment
il allait faire c'était il était très
angoissée pour apprendre son texte
vraiment quelque chose qui l'angoissé
moi je veux faisait répéter à buddh
plaisir et beaucoup c'est au oui oui
parce que ça l'angoissé la mémoire c'est
un vrai c'est terriblement j'ai pas
souvenir de son fait il a fait une
tournée monstrueuse enfin bruno dalles
ouais mais c'était super cesse je crois
que ces lettres vous l'accompagnez vue
ouais ouais ouais ça c'est oui oui
c'était magnifique c'était magnifique
cette tournée ça la tenue envie celle là
c'était une belle tournée des biens de
partir comme ça oui c'était bien et fait
cesser ses premières parties et beaucoup
et dans les tournées vous montiez pour
chanter calamity de oui voilà on avait
notre rendez vous à ces tests et autres
rendez vous on était heureuse
est-ce que ça a un rapport j'allais
presque dire un peu mystique quand vous
avez chanté ensemble cantique des
cantiques comme une chose assez
extraordinaire est-ce qu'il avait un
rapport à la fois particulier
pas du tout on avait tous les deux le
même rapport à la fois sincère que quand
on a décidé de se marier
on s'est dit la mairie est ce que ça
nous suffit
non ça ne suffit pas on veut du sacré
donc voilà on veut du sacré qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec ça
toi tu es lui il était il était divorcé
plusieurs fois moi je suis pas baptisé
on ne va pas à l'église on prend pas en
jésus-christ mais on croit on prend
l'amour dans la musique on croit aux
étoiles on croit aussi nous prêtres la
chose donc on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on
fait on va voir le curé du village du
bled qu'on sait on s'est mariés et puis
voilà on dit ça au curé et le pur et
nous dit je vous comprends alors je peux
pas je peux rien faires d'officiel mais
je vous accueille et vous faites ce que
vous voulez il est très généreux de sa
part et donc on voit là olivier cadiot
venait de traduire le cantique des
cantiques dans une forme 10 cibles comme
ça on prouve l hôpital maudier et et
puis voilà ça s'est fait naturellement
dernière chose qui sera un peu notre
conclusion cette soirée des victoires
vous êtes dans la salle comment ça se
passe là bas non mais moi quand il
chante un jour je sourirai - où on est
tous effondrés derrière parce que on le
voit tout maigre tout le maigre on
savait même pas s'il allait tenir debout
il est passé la journée à l'umj
et pas bien
ah non c'était on était en apnée un
dernière née des rapts et puis moi quand
il s'est mis à chanter
j'étais là au munster c'était trop
évident vous chanter cette chanson
c'était trop évident oui mais c'est quoi
merci merci nous avoir parlé si joliment
d'alain bashung
[Musique]